hello so today I'm gonna tell you about
a thing I love things well that's
fortunate
today's thing is this stick end for the
last four years my friend Mars Dyer has
hosted a 24-hour live chat on the
internet to raise money for the
children's charity UNICEF Mars is a very
good friend of mine in fact he was the
first youtuber that I ever met up with
in person so when he came to me and said
hey Charlie do you want to co-present
stick code with me this year I was like
yes I would like to co-presenters de
Kate with you this year and now I'm here
to tell you that on the 4th of September
for your entertainment I'm going to be
trying to stay up for 24 hours straight
you've done stick a four times now what
does staying up for 24 hours do to you
mentally well it completely drains you
makes you lose all your energy until you
feel like an empty shell that sounds
like fun
it's only now that stick aid is less
than a week away that I'm starting to
think oh god I mean I'm the kind of
person who calls going to bed 1/2 11:00
a late night I quite like sleeping you
know it's it's a nice thing to do so I'm
unsure how I'm going to manage to stay
up for 24 consecutive hours without
going completely insane how enough do
you stay up for 24 hours without going
completely insane
well you just don't know I'm going mad
just thinking about it and to adds to
the insanity not only are we staying up
for 24 hours but we're also trying to
get people to donate money to charity
which basically means spending those 24
hours doing really stupid things for
example last year's climax was miles
getting guns poured all over his head
and this year there are already talked
about shooting each other with paintball
guns however we are going to be giving
most of the control in terms of what
challenges we actually do up to you guys
and you know I have faith that you're
not going to get us to do anything too
uncomfortable right what kind of
challenge ideas did people come up with
last year that you had to do well I had
to run around outside in just my boxers
I had to talk in my best American accent
for half an hour I had to wax my legs
and I had to do the Macarena you had to
do the Macarena
yeah that's just cruel but you know what
that's what charity events are all about
convincing people to give money to those
who are less fortunate by doing the most
idiotic things that you can possibly
think of honestly as much as I am
worried about how stick aid is going to
affect my mental health more than any
I'm just excited we've set ourselves a
big target this year what's our target
10,000 pounds which is approximately
$15,000 and when I say that we've set
ourselves a big target this year I don't
mean ourselves is in me and miles
I mean ourselves is in us anew I mean
stickit isn't really a show as much as
it is a community event the whole idea
about having it gone for 24 hours is
daunting as that seems to be now is that
it doesn't really matter what time zone
you're in hopefully during the 24 hours
there will be at least some point where
you can pop in and say hello hello so
September the poor starting 12 noon UK
time which is 7:00 a.m. Eastern Time for
24 hours you can find more information
at stick aid 2010 . info and that's also
where the live show will be happening
now we'll see you there hopefully please
come bye bye wait I'm just in the middle
of editing this video at the moment and
I want to interject and tell you that I
have an idea I thought it would be cool
as part of sticking to do a live
challenge Charlie that I would film and
turn into a video so if you have any
ideas for a challenge please do leave a
suggestion in the comments I will pick
one and do it okay
goodbye for real this time bye you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool for the last four
years my friend Myles Dyer is face okay
thanks